Whether you like it or not you're now a superhero
very good i'm just trying to
show you no i'm done i'm shown
i did not go to law school to become a vigilante
our universe is on the edge of a precipice
all right let's do this who the hell are you
that name better not stick i'm not gonna be a
superhero what else you're
gonna do as a hulk lawyer
we just started a superhuman law division
and i want the she-hulk to be the evasive
we do things by the book the book of
the shanty the book of american uh loss
Welcome back everyone this will be my new she-hulk
trailer there's a whole bunch of new daredevil
scenes so we'll break it down i know you have lots
of questions about what's going on with daredevil
in the mcu time to get yourself a really good
lawyer and now we have two of them in the mcu
if you're brand new to the channel i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes it's going to start
really soon be sure to subscribe to get them all
it's going to be crazy there's going to be a bunch
of cameo scenes and i'll explain how it connects
to everything during my episode easter egg videos
but just starting with this big daredevil scene
first so he rolls in to the roof of a parking
garage riding on the roof of a green porch
obviously big reference to she-hulk herself
because she is this giant green lawyer and
because she's still kind of learning to be
a superhero she's not quite as nimble as other
heroes and they make a joke about how she just
kind of turns around and doesn't do anything just
she just stands there and she's so strong that
the porsche just wrecks itself on her stopping
it dead in his tracks doesn't even scratch her
and daredevil basically recovers by nimbly jumping
and flipping through the air landing in a very
daredevil graceful kind of way and i love the
way they play this scene too because he kind of
turns his ear to face or because that's the way
that blind people would normally do it like they
lead with their ears they don't lead with their
eyes like normal people when they look around
to find where something is coming from because
he's using his special daredevil ability his
ears to hear where things are coming from the way
they explain daredevil's special ability though
he's not a mutant or anything like that he's more
like a mutate if you want to get technical about
it because he did get his powers during a big
chemical spill like he wasn't born blind they
dealt with that during like the very first episode
of the daredevil netflix series when he loses his
sight his other senses get a little bit stronger
like normal people who are blind but because this
is the marvel universe we're talking about the
mcu like there's this extra level of ability on
top of that his daredevil sight seeing the world
in red is like a much greater level of detail that
like he senses the world and his brain sort of
puts that information together to form these
objects in a visual sense so he kind of interprets
things in a visual way but using auditory cues
that's why his ability is so much stronger than
like a normal blind person's he tried to explain
this to karen page one time too she's like wait
a minute you can see you've been lying this whole
time he's like well no i can't really see it's
kind of like seeing but it's not the same thing
as actually having sight you see a much better
look at the yellow costume this is made to look
like his first comic book costume so if you don't
remember most people just think of the red costume
when they think of daredevil or they think of
the black costume but originally when daredevil
debuted in the comics for the first time he wore
a version of this yellow costume they brought it
back a couple times throughout the comics like
normally you see him in the red costume because
you think of the frank miller run and that's
mostly him in the red costume or wearing the
classic black costume but the crazy thing here is
that it almost looks exactly like his daredevil
netflix red costume like they try to keep it in
continuity as much as possible so it looks like
an evolution of his previous costume that he wore
during daredevil season 1 and season 2. they could
also explain that this yellow costume is yellow
like this like it's a new version of the costume
because of what happened during daredevil season
3. lego there was a villain running around
in this version of the costume for a long time
so i kind of had to get rid of that costume
i know a lot of you are asking now does this mean
that the events of the daredevil netflix series
are canon now completely to the mcu the answer is
yes they're canon but not a hundred percent like
some things are canon but not like every little
thing they'll reference things during the events
of the daredevil netflix episodes but he's kind of
meant to be a little bit of a reimagining of the
character so it's kind of canon but not completely
canon the same is true for the kingpin and all
the other daredevil netflix and marvel netflix
characters in general like if luke cage comes back
if jessica jones comes back same thing with them
the reason why they're doing it that way is just
because kevin feige and the marvel people want the
freedom to do what they want to with the character
to sort of like creatively retune what their
costumes look like and keep things in continuity
without having to reference every little thing
that happened like yes these are meant to be the
same characters but we're not going to go back and
reference like every minute little detail because
during this scene where they're kind of going
at each other a little bit you see her wearing
the new version of her comic book accurate costume
i'm assuming it's happening in some of the later
episodes because i think part of the timeline
of the show is that she has a version of her
origin story with the bruce banner version of the
hook he sort of teaches her how to use her powers
a little bit and then eventually she goes back to
los angeles to be this green giant lawyer and then
you pick up with the events of the series where
you see a lot of the cameos like you see wong show
up you see titania a lot of the other cameos show
up and eventually daredevil shows up on a case
as matt murdock and then later as daredevil and
because during a lot of these disney plush shows
they give them their comic book accurate costumes
towards the end of the series i'm assuming that
the daredevil episodes will be happening either
like later in the episodes or like he'll show
up as matt murdock for the first time in earlier
episodes and then later episodes as daredevil so
i'm assuming this rooftop fight scene that they're
having here or whatever the scene winds up being
is happening in the later episodes he is supposed
to get a new version of his classic red costume
when he appears again i believe that's during
the echo series and that'll happen next year and
then in the daredevil born again series which they
just confirmed they'll be 18 episodes of that he's
supposed to get a version of his black costume
but it's going to be the back in black costume
the whole thing with the title daredevil born
again obviously reminds you of the comic book run
born again they actually adapted part of that
comic book story for daredevil season three and it
was just the part of the story where kingpin does
everything he can to tear down daredevil's life
and mac murdock's life as a lawyer like he has
two different personas he tears them both down
so that he hits his lowest point and has to sort
of work himself out of that hole and rebuild
himself as a stronger more hardcore version of
daredevil but they're also kind of using the
title because he's sort of born again into the mcu
sort of sort of a wink from behind the camera like
ha ha we got the character back from netflix in
a few weeks when they eventually air his episodes
they'll start talking a lot more about the future
of daredevil all the netflix characters inside the
mcu so don't worry there'll be lots of daredevil
stuff happening really soon there's a couple
brand new scenes of she-hulk going full savage
she-hulk which is usually what you think of when
you think of the green she-hulk in the comics
when she's not walking around being sort of
like the half-and-half very controlled professor
hulk version of her hulk self that's one of the
differences between she-hulk and incredible hulk
in the classic comics is that usually she always
walks around like this where she's like in this
half and half state where she has the power of
her hulk but also the mind of jennifer walters
the one weakness when they're in this balanced
state and it's all versions of the hook like
if you're talking about the bruce banner hulk
or the jennifer walter hulk or any of the other
members of the hulk family is that they're weaker
when they go into their full hulk state like this
is what she looks like as full hulk they get way
stronger but they become way more mindless way
less controllable you also notice when she goes
full savage she-hulk here just kind of losing it
she's wearing the led zeppelin t-shirt you also
see incredible hulk bruce banner clowning on her
during their training montage when he shows her up
during that boulder throwing contest by literally
launching a boulder into outer space like you can
see it burning up as it exits the atmosphere
there are a couple other moments where you
see her opening up on what looks like the wrecking
crew here like she kind of loses it like she seems
more zen but then she loses it a couple times we
get a couple more courtroom scenes with titania
versus she-hulk i can't talk about her too much
without getting into too many spoilers about what
she's actually doing during the series but a lot
of you that have been asking about like particular
details about her transformation between jennifer
walters and she hulk you actually see sort of like
a halfway version of a she-hulk with curly hair
like she's in the middle of her transformation
there were so many weird questions about why she
has straight hair when she becomes she-hulk but
she has curly hair when she's jennifer walters
the real reason for that i think is just because
she looks more like this in the comics so they
wanted her to have straight hair when she's in
full she-hulk form so when her body's transforming
into her hulk state it also transforms her hair
which does seem kind of weird but i guess it's
just the way they're explaining it on the show
in all the new scenes of wong are taking place
in the same fight scene inside this magic club
the whole thing with wong during the series
is i believe he shows up because he's actually
using her to sue this other magician during
the series who's pretending to be a sorcerer
that's also the same magic club where we got the
ghost rider easter egg in the previous trailer
even though it does seem like wong is becoming the
new version of nick fury just crossing over into
everybody's marvel movie in marvel disney plus
series we will see nick fury come back during
the secret invasion series i think part of the
idea though is that like samuel l jackson in real
life just practically is getting up there in age
and he's getting more and more expensive the more
times that they have him in movies so they're just
looking for other options for other big crossover
characters to help them connect everything across
films i know everybody would love to see deadpool
become one of those characters too like him just
showing up randomly in everyone else's projects
we might see deadpool show up in a cameo scene
before the actual deadpool 3 movies release
because it doesn't seem like deadpool 3 will
come out till marvel phase 6 in one of these
mystery dates here if you spotted any other
easter eggs in the new trailer footage that
i didn't mention in the video just write them
below in the comments all my she-hulk episodes
will start posting in a couple weeks we don't have
to wait that long before we actually get episodes
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss anything there is a special guardians
of the galaxy groot episode that's dropping next
week it's like a one-off with a bunch of shorts
i will also do a video for that that's going to
be like the week before she-hulk the week after
that is when she-hulk episode 1 drops everyone
click here for my she-hulk world war hulk video
and thunderbolts connections because it
is connected to the thunderbolts series
and click here for my new guardians of
the galaxy 3 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!